here is glass now and that era of 6.08
as Tom said was wild in game one ended
up walking six to go with his 8ks look
for bets to do something early that is
into left crunched by bats he's got to
think to it he'll make it easily a
lead-off double for the Dodgers and if
La wants to eliminate the bad taste in a
crushing defeat from game four the way
to do that is to jump on the scoreboard
here early Corey Seeger coming up Seeger
7 for 14 in the World Series finds one
in the right field right Fields hit
fetch rounding third he is on his way
home and he
[Applause]
well statement made early but they need
to be able to close it out there's a
long way to go in this one so it's first
and second now here's Ellen Bellinger
taking inside and low and is blocked by
zenino but tips off the foot of Home
Plate umpire Marvin Hudson and as a
result Seeger goes to third well there's
an early tilting Point again for the
Dodgers Runner first goes the pitch
rounded into the shift back headed by
Lao from his knees they'll have no play
and the base running of Corey Seger just
made it to nothing to Third on a wild
pitch that didn't go far and scores on
an infield hit a lead-off single for
yondi Diaz in the bottom half of the
first and here is Brandy arazzarin he
has goes Brown ball the short Seeger
flips the second out at second on the
first double play that's one way to get
a reason a rosarina with a double play
two out Seeger to tailored amongst doc
Peterson leads off in the second Innings
Peterson on a 1-2 pitch well struck out
to deep center field and gone
28th home run of this postseason for the
Dodgers and the second for jock Chuck
Peterson his second home run of the
postseason and the Dodgers take a three
to nothing lead one out one on Diaz but
off the bottom of the First with a base
hit here's one into right field that's
going to get down bats can't get to it
digging around second and now headed to
third is Kiermaier they're going to
bring him to the plate Diaz all the way
to Third and that released to the base
and Diaz is safe and sliced one down the
right field nine right there and Bets
with a risky proposition is trying to
get to it before it banged off the wall
and instead of Angling after 31 the
straight line after it he has a third
with only one out Randy or rosarina
coming up swing and a hard ground ball
base headed to left field there's a hit
with runners in scoring position Diaz
scores but rosarina drives him in to
make it a one-run game and the rosary
ain't able to stay back and then shoot
it through the left side so the Rays had
a bit of an answer here so a roads are
raining with his first hit with a runner
and scoring position this postseason
first and third two away here's
Kiermaier Marco breaks for home the
pitch on the way is high and the tacky
as hell there will be no replay Margot
is out at the plate attempting to steal
home plate and Kershaw with the Aid at
The Dugout makes the play orange the tag
out and the inning is over now Max
Muncie walked in single here's the 3-2
swing and driving
oh baby
and he knew it off the bat Santa Maria
and the Dodgers take a 4-2 lead
muncie's third home run of the
postseason got it all left nothing
behind the absolutely crushed it one
ball two strikes Kiermaier Strikes Out
Swinging on a fastball up and in yeah
Kershaw is now the all-time strikeout
leader in postseason play that was 206.
here is Brandon Lau first pitch to him
is lifted in the air on the right side
of the infield who's got it first
baseman Max muncie's waving everybody
off and there's two pitches crowd is
groaning here as Roberts came out and
that's it he threw two pitches here in
the sixth
Dodger fans don't want to see Kershaw
come out
and while Margo is coming up Dustin may
stop is electric when he's on it's just
the last few times out he hasn't been on
as he deals with Margo with two out
nobody aboard great job swinging on a
101 mile an hour fastball no runs no
hits no errors nobody left Dustin may
win an inning and two-thirds here Meyer
is his statistical responsibility as
soon as Gonzalez was announced into the
game Kevin cash desired a pinch hit for
the pinch hitter so now it's going to be
Mike brosso
here's a rose Arena where the tying runs
on and only one out in the eighth inning
this is the best chance of the night for
Tampa Bay first pitch for the Fly ball
to center field Bellinger retreating he
will make the catch the runners stay put
and there's two out of the Dodgers
debris the sigh of relief Arena
he is retired on one pitch and now the
Dodgers get the match up with Gonzalez
against the left-handed hitting Brandon
Lau wow
a little short fly into center field and
Bellinger comes in with all the speed
and makes the catch and that will end
the inning no runs one hit two left the
Dodgers three outs away from taking a
three games to two lead in the World
Series and this game now is up to Willie
Adamas and down he goes swung on and
missed strike three the Dodgers beat the
Rays four to two they now lead the world
series three games to two Dodgers are
one win away
winning the World Series